I was a student at Cass Technical High
School in Detroit Michigan in my teacher
Marilyn McCormick won the 2016
excellence in theatre education award
Marilyn was a huge influence on me and
still is in fact she was the first
person on Cod when I got the lead role
in Roxanne Roxanne miss McCormack who we
lovingly call MC introduced me to the
drama program at Carnegie Mellon
University Thank You MC now it's time
for your amazing theater teacher to make
history submit your teacher's name for
the 2019 excellence in theatre education
award go to Tony Awards calm now and
into the K through 12 drama teacher that
made a difference in your life